le moment à 19h48 c'est le jt avant le
jt tu vas faire la connaissance d'un
garçon qui s'appelle patrick chanterai
qui est très sympathique c'est parti
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir cyril vous en est un autre
quelqu'un d'autre je suis très heureux
de nous retrouver là bas aussi
effectivement et on commence tout de
suite avec une news
j'avais égaliser oui c'était c'était des
cheveux que je vois là que je gardais en
location pilane yard n'a été retiré dans
batman à écouter ça va extrêmement bien
merci
vous aurez d un autre de quoi faire et
tant mieux si on est narrée par la santé
la santé c'est d'abord la santé on
commence par une zone type effectivement
santé tous les plateaux télé on leur
médecin expert et pmp hausse est
désormais le sien de médecins experts ce
qui va enfin nous éclairer sur les
déclarations du ministre de la santé
le numéro nice aux lumières qu'ils sont
[Musique]
battus cépages année calme toi bats
calme toi tu te reprend on vous écoute
docteur
depuis juillet plusieurs départements
ont progressivement basculer de la zone
verte en zone rouge
et j'ai lu qq tout rouge comme on les
bat bruine abaissement de la jauge des
rassemblements à 1000 personnes
vous le prenez vraiment pour des cons
fermeture anticipée débat qui aiment pas
bonne cela nous permet donc sur chaque
territoire d'appréhender la situation
avec des indicateurs très précis il
taira pas les qualités à la pâte est le
concert le col mao juma bat les couilles
à tana ça continue à chirac or là je
mesure pleinement les efforts que chacun
d'entre nous réalise au quotidien
regardez la solide elle est répartie la
solidarité movie amassés en chromé seco
je fais la connaissance de rené vous
connaissiez mais se découvrent ah oui
vous allez plus pouvoir vous en passer
les succulents politiques qui continuent
effectivement par news de type politique
suite aux récentes déclarations de la
ministre des armées florence parly à
l'aller bah tiens même où le
gouvernement avait si j'aimais bien ça
c'est vrai des trains bahri ben ali ait
passé déjà un tube à ce mélomane
mélomanes c'est un super héros le
gouvernement a décidé de se lancer dans
la production de films de féerie et
d'animation en réalisant le mc de
pinocchio regardez
[Musique]
au rapatriement des français 2 orane est
il responsable du début de la
contamination dans l'oise absurde non
pas l'équipage a été réveillé pendant 14
jours
ils ont été testés ils n'étaient pas
porteurs du virus
ces personnes ont été testées et ne sont
pas malades et aucun des membres
d'équipage l'espérait n'est malade ayant
juré de dire la vérité je me dois de
vous dire que j'ai dit quelque chose d'
inexact le 4 mars à france dut donc en
effet il n'y a pas eu de test pcr jeu je
prie chacun de m'excuser
comme quoi c c'est bon le cinéma c'est
beau effectivement des conclusions sont
moins bonnes
complètement hors et bien oui continuez
part du sport pour cette rubrique bien
évidemment je vais commencer par parler
moins fort techniquement vient ça va
être pénible par un bon tout le monde
lors j d'agglo mais partout d'ailleurs
on est deux à avoir ce genre de problème
en europe il ya moi et nelson monfort
ah oui pas peut-être même nelson trop
fort on le regarde c'est nelson monfort
bonjour nelson am c'est non
nous avons sur le court numéro sept
jihadistes merci messieurs les
journalistes s'il vous plaît je suis ici
sur cette magnifique terre sainte le
village le village un petit peu comme la
météo sur le dos des hauts et des bas
s'il vous plaît mais elles sont s'il
vous plaît merci
oh
très à l'aise c'est comme ça qu'on les
aime aussi ben voilà on va terminer par
l'international international je suis
aux touristes citizen
d'ailleurs c'est la minute qu au ces la
minute ina c'est la minute
si chez nos députés français les débats
sont parfois chaud chez nos amis
argentins les débats sont mouthe
carrément show mucho calliente comme on
dit là-bas à manaus ars députés mais la
balle orange foot à la cia sociale non
[Musique]
ah oui tu donnerais des pizzas
on va expliquer aux téléspectateurs
effectivement ce qu'ils font ils font
donc ils sont tous voila tout à fait qui
est apparemment de ma famille plaisir
[Applaudissements]